الجديد نسخه من التويتر لكن من دون الون
ماسك
وتويتر يتشابهان تدوينات ورسائل قصيره
يمكن للمستخدم مشاركتها مع المتابعين
نشر النصوص والصور والروابط ومقاطع
الفيديو سهل الاستخدام كتويتر لكنه يشترط
امتلاك المستخدم لحساب على انستجرام
تويتر يتفوق بميزات عده لا يمتلك موجزه
متابعين ويوفر حاليا موجزا خوارزميا
رئيسيا واحدا
الموجز يتضمن منشورات اشخاص تتابعهم
واشخاص مشهورين بالخدمه تعديل المشاركات
متاح في تويتر بلو ولكنه مفقود على ست
يحدد عدد الاحرف بخمسمائه وخمسين ولا ينذر
بتجاوز الحد الا بعد النشر
استخدموا ستريتس يمكنه البحث عن حسابات
اخرى فقط وليس كلمات في منشوراته
الرسائل المباشره غير متاحه بل تمر عبر
انستقرام
التطبيق متاح في اكثر من مئه دوله
باستثناء الاتحاد الاوروبي اما بشان
الخصوصيه متى قد تجمع بيانات كثيره من
التطبيق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات